another reminder tonight of a hard truth
a lot of teenagers have struggled during
this pandemic and tonight mental health
experts are saying that we really need
to remember to keep a close eye on our
kids well-being sally jaramillo is live
outside of centennial hills high school
where the principal informed families
that one of their students died by
suicide sally
denise tonight very sad news here at the
school
and a reminder to parents stay alert
especially when it comes to the mental
well-being of your children
i think whenever somebody takes their
life it's just
it's very difficult it will be a hard
road for students at centennial high
school when i heard that i was yeah i
was i was heartbroken of course and
you know my you know i was in my heart
goes out to the family and in the in
the peers of that of that student
unfortunately it's not an isolated
incident emergency rooms for suicide
attempts in boys only rose 3.7 percent
it jumped 51 percent for girls we just
have to be really alert and aware right
now that our kids have been struggling
for a couple of years child and
adolescent psychiatrist and assistant
professor at the kirker corgan school of
medicine at unlv says one of the main
culprits social media you need to be
aware of where your kid is on social
media parents should be aware of the
social media accounts kids are following
and watch for signs they may be in
trouble they start to sell their
possessions give away their possessions
if you see a child who's starting to
hurt themselves on purpose
who's having withdrawal from their
friends their peers dr sheldon jacobs
reminds parents to have open
conversations with their kids being
tuned to your kids make sure you're
listening to them
back out live we've been working on an
entire series of how to help your
children just go to eight news now dot
com and click on the cyber safe parent
tab for more details sally jaramillo
live local now